hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought a big piece of land and our
prototype with a more sustainable way of
living
not sure how it's going to go but let's
see and in the previous video you've
seen us setting up the base camp
with the shipping containers but now
what we actually need there is
water and on the land itself we have a
few sources of water
and like here this lake we cleaned up
and in this video we're going to do some
water testing to see if the water is
drinkable
what we need to do to filter it so we're
going to
fill up some jars and do some testing
[Music]
all right so the first test is the water
from this lake it looks sort of okay
not super clean but we i guess we only
really know once we test it to see how
drinkable it is
but this place would be the best source
of water because it's very close to the
base camp so it would be by far
the easiest one but we also gonna get
two other places on the land the creek
and the swamp
so we're gonna get some water and then
we'll run some tests
so on to the next location this one
so you might have seen us cleaning the
swamp in the other update videos
uh slowly plants are actually growing
back so we have to take care of that
but this thing starts to blossom which
is nice but yeah we're here for the
water
all right so we have our water for the
swamp and now we have to go there in the
back
to the creek
destination reached
[Applause]
the water from the creek feels most
fresh by far probably because of running
water compared to the other ones
but the downside of this one is it could
easily change i mean depends on what
the flow is coming from and it's quite
far from base camp so it would be hard
to get drinking water
but let's see what the tests are going
to show us all right so let's get on
with our very professional setting
all right so here we have our three
waters lake swamp
and the creek they look pretty similar
to be honest looking at them from each
other the swamp has some green stuff on
it
and the creek is the coolest one these
ones are a bit warmer
but let's do some testing so we're going
to do two different tests from different
brands the first one is this tiny
package
so i bought two of these in a package
for 16 euro
so quite affordable i would say the
second test is going to be the 16 in one
water test kit
this one has a lot of packages in the
site
for different tests this one was also
around 60 euro
so quite a bit more but it also has more
tests all right so let's get started
so we're going to start off with the
simple tests so the package basically
contains a lot of
test strips and then you dip it in the
water for a few seconds and then you see
according to these
little color cubes what it actually
means
so for instance this test measures
chlorine
iron copper lead nitrate nitrate
the total water hardness the total
alkalinity
and ph levels seems pretty
straightforward you dip it in for two to
three seconds and then within one minute
you read the results
so let's try it out
so it looks like a lot of copper and
left in here
although they also seem a bit unchanged
these colors
okay okay and the yellow actually got
more green
alright so let's test them all and write
down the results
next one the swamp
last one the creek
so the results seem pretty similar which
could be the case
because the water is relatively close to
each other
the only real difference is one i saw
more copper than the other
but i'm not sure if i just read this
thing inaccurate because
i mean could be 50 could be 20
i don't know in general the only thing i
really saw
changing from the original color was
the alkalinity which really went from
more yellow to green let's get on the
next test which is the
more expensive one has a few more of
these bags inside
it also has a little plastic thing
to put in a joint to put in your water
testing
kind of useless and the little chart
to write down your tests the strips
looks very similar compared to the other
one
except this one has more things to
measure so it also has for instance mps
fluorite acid ammonia bromine
carbonate i don't know yeah
a similar process here put it into the
water for two to three seconds but then
they say hold it horizontally for 30 to
50 seconds which i didn't do with the
other one
and then also again in 30 seconds you
read
the results one
two three
oh you see this one changing actually
all right let's have a look
hardness 25
so ammonia should be between red and
yellow but it
became green alright
next
also this one looks very similar to the
previous one let's have a look now at
the last one
so this package actually gives you a
reference where you should be so
this is sort of the okay area so you can
instantly check as well if it's okay
but even this is quite hard so for
instance if you have fluoride
i mean the 100 plus is really different
color i mean slightly different
but these look so identical so it's
super hard to even say
which one it is but then these are not
good and this one is good
which makes it quite tricky i'll
continue to do a few more tests because
i have plenty of strips and then i can
see if
the results are consistent and then it's
a bit messy but i'll show you a nice
chart right
now all right so here we have the chart
here you can see all the things that we
measured and then let's start with the
lake
and the first test these were the
results and then with the second test
we got a bit more because the test was a
bit more advanced same for the swamp
and for the creek so these are an
overview of all the results
a few noteworthy things for instance
here you can see the lat which is kind
of an important one
quite a big difference between 50 and 0
for the lake and
also for instance here they both test
show zero and both show 40. so i don't
know if it's really in the water or just
the test being not very accurate now
these tests were pretty easy to do and
to get
so in a way a good way to check your
water but i also don't really trust them
i mean it seems too good to be true so
just to find out if they're accurate and
to see if they're actually
useful we're also going to send one
sample of
each water type to a laboratory and in
one they're going to do a micro
bacterial test and then the other one
a chemical test so time to go to the
laboratory
this is a bonus round to see if it
actually does something with different
liquids
[Music]
alkalinity chlorine zero
that looks like this one thank you
[Music]
so this is my b and this is the swamp
a lot of similarities except for
chlorine i have less chlorine than the
swamp
so now we're going to bring these
bottles to the laboratory here where
they're going to do
a water analysis
so we just brought the water samples now
we have to wait eight days
yeah we don't like waiting so
all right so here we have the water
tests back in an envelope
let's check it out
okay that looks very compact
it is in portuguese with a lot of things
i don't know
let me translate and put it in a chart
okay so let's have another look at this
very exciting chart
and so we have test one task two lake
swamp and the creek so these are all the
results
and now let's make some space so we can
add the third test
which is the laboratory one and
obviously aligning things a bit
so if you dump in all the information
it's actually quite a bit more because i
just measured more things
like phosphate potassium
atrocious clostridium
yeah i don't know this stuff i might
need another translation to just
understand this but it has it's also
way more information which the other
tests don't have
um and it also actually has missing some
information which the other test
did have so it feels quite incomplete
in terms of how to really compare some
numbers so we really want to compare
numbers that we had from all the three
tests
we end up with this charts is the
nitrate nitrate chlorine iron hardness
and ph
um so it's not that much and some
interesting things for instance the
nitrates we got zero in the other tests
and here it has
more like 2.4 2.2
same for chlorine uh we had very little
in the
uh other tests test one and two but way
more
in this laboratory test and if we add uh
this other chart
we can also see what it actually means
so for instance what does it mean to
have more nitrate or more chlorine
so here we added this thing that it says
what it should be
so for instance here for the nitrate 50
is mandatory maximum 50 so we're still
in that limit um but you also have
options
uh like iron which they it's not
mandatory by law but they sort of use it
as a reference
and but also here here you actually see
quite a big difference between the lake
and the swamp and the creek
so it was kind of difficult to really
compare these tests with each other
because the variables are so different
but the main thing we got from the
laboratory of all the three areas was
it's not drinkable the water
and if you want to make it drinkable you
need to do something like
filtering it um but it's still a bit
difficult because
first you understand need to understand
which kind of filter but also it might
depend on which time of the year
or when you measure it and at this point
we don't really have a full overview of
what's going to happen a whole year
around
in these water areas so it would require
a bit more
measuring um so in general it felt like
kind of a big topic if you really want
to make sure we can get proper drinking
water from
these areas so we've been looking a bit
into getting a borehole
just to get us started with the drinking
water to make sure it comes
from a fresh source in the earth
so if it comes out you don't really need
to filter it most likely
because it's pretty pure which would be
quite an
easy step for us to go into water to
drink
and then over time phase it out and
understand more what the lake does
and the swamp does to see how we can get
drinking water out of that
so yeah that was what we learned from
all these water tests hope it was useful
for you guys
thank you guys on patreon for making
sure we can't afford these water tests
and because we don't really need to do
this in a way but it's also
uh i think many other people would have
this question like which water test and
how to do it
so it's fun to try it out and hopefully
make it a bit easier for you guys
uh if you're in the same position to
understand what to do with your
water anyway that's it thanks for
watching
if you want to make sure to see the
video that comes next
subscribe and yeah otherwise i'll see
you there
thanks for watching